je suis très en colère contre koh lanta
maintenant vous êtes en colère mais
sympa réalisme car vous m'avez ils
étaient en colère mais roule
il m'a dit d'être calme c'est vrai alors
sympa avec les quatre équipes régionales
on savait qu'on tomberait dans la
caricature d'aller vite mais à ce point
là
jamais j'aurais imaginé ça devient une
télé réalité c'est les marseillais
contre les ch'tis
même les candidats ont le profil de
candidats de télé-réalité laventure y en
a plus y'a que des clashs et des
mauvaises punchline moi je vous le dise
cyril aujourd'hui koh lanta est en
danger alors vraiment en danger à 5
millions et demi on n'a pas bien alors
demandé de m'appeler fait l'émission en
face de koh lanta
bah oui c'est très fort ça reste très
fort alors ce qui a particulièrement
marqué les téléspectateurs dans cet
épisode c'est l'ambiance chez les bleus
voulaient ni à quatre équipes
l'équipe du sud suite à leur défaite à
l'épreuve d'immunité alors qu'ils disent
est une grande famille tout vole en
éclats regardez c'est la famille en or
mais version catastrophe regarde toi ça
toujours fait le devin pourquoi tu
voulais que toujours la chef pourquoi
jeter ma c'est parce que les addicts à
gré satigui je voulais pour une eau midi
aujourd'hui c'est moi non aujourd'hui
c'est moi qui me suis traînée l'athlète
dans la bourre pour pas qu'on ait à
avoir deux conseils c'est moi c'est quoi
les choses non gelée
moi je fais pas les choses parce que
cela
fou c'est beaucoup plus tard monnaie
maintenant pas gris à faire
un branchement deux mois mais mais nous
tenons surtout papier et à la poutre a
compris
viola
on dit qu'on était chez les ch'tis
hamiani oulémas jean pascal a battu riez
et moi personnellement je n'aime pas
trop voir des gens qui attendent sur une
poutre pour bouffer un sticker ça m'a
jamais tenté mais non mais c'est vrai
qu'on retrouve un peu trop maintenant
l'esprit des oranges ou des trucs comme
ça serait que ça changeait ses batteries
à partir du moment où tu vois que ça
marche quand même très bien sûr
justement ça plaise charmant aux gens je
vous de voir c'est aussi là après on dit
que là c'est dire que l'on compte
histoire c'est juste les gens dit il
mais ça a changé par rapport à la banque
ce même pour l'ouïe mais ça a changé
mais ça plaît
oui mais tu mets quand même les
conversations des dizaines d autres d'un
côté c'est pas exactement la même chose
puis surtout eu une mouche quand même le
maillot pour le même motif
pardonne moi mais ils sont vraiment des
trucs alors que les revenus norme
absolue c'est quand elle se casse un
ongle
je suis sûr que ça mérite pas un tel
impôt et maintenant la cadence bijoux en
fait quand on entend du bruit
quant à ses nervis garder mais gallas
gardez le pour la syrie non mais c'est
vrai oui ben non je disais que c'est non
c'est pas encore télé réalité parce que
déjà c'est la vraie vie tu pars en
vacances avec la famille passe
exactement d'un état et surtout dans koh
lanta on l'a vu en pleurs quand on
retrouve son slip en de la terre et on
met pas de slip il a raison le grand
événement de ce vendredi c'est que
françois le candidat basque avec quel
but il avait perdu son slip plus rapide
il a vu tomber dans le jeu de maillots
mais [ __ ] c'est pas possible
j'étais la semaine dernière aucun
véritable drame jour n'ont parlé je sais
que vous aussi chez ou avec vos amis
avec votre interview françois perdu son
seul bien de ceux alloués soit à
retrouver et on a les images
alléluia
[Musique]
énorme quel plaisir quelle quelle joie
un plaisir simple je préférerais avoir
le même plaisir avec le feu et déjà pour
je suis personne peut être dira pas tout
mais je sais pas mais je sais pas
comment je les ai vues elles lui il ya
venu de nulle part a baissé la veille
[Applaudissements]
et
que penser des chrétiens de sondage
allez on va voir d'accord jugé trop
téléralité d'accord à 63% pas d'accord à
37% pour l'instant en tout cas ça tient
très bien ça cartonne